digamos que aceptas prestarme algo de
dinero
digamos que estás de acuerdo con
prestarme 100 pesos y te pregunto si
está bien que te pague 100 pesos y tú
dices que no que me quieres cobrar
interés y yo te pregunto cuánto interés
quieres cobrar y me dices que quieres
cobrar el 5 por ciento de interés anual
entonces una manera de pensar en esto es
si hoy me presta 100 pesos en un año
tendré que pagarte 100 pesos y tengo que
aumentarle el 5% lo cual es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 1.05 esto es lo que te
tengo que pagar voy a escribir préstamo
y pago entonces esta tasa de interés que
solo representa el valor nominal de lo
que tengo que pagar se conoce como tasa
de interés nominal
y podemos compararla con la tasa de
interés real y tal vez te preguntes por
qué necesitamos otro tipo de tasa de
interés bueno aunque en el valor nominal
te estoy pagando un 5% más eso no
significa que podrás comprar 5% más con
el dinero que te estoy pagando y tal vez
te preguntes por qué
y la respuesta es por la inflación con
105 pesos no necesariamente podrás
comprar lo mismo dentro de un año que lo
que puedes comprar hoy y eso es lo que
tratamos de calcular con la tasa de
interés real y para hacer eso para
calcular la tasa de interés real tenemos
que tener presente la inflación así que
déjenme escribir
inflación por aquí y digamos que vivimos
en un mundo que tiene una inflación del
2% entonces un indicador es una canasta
de bienes que hoy cuesta 100 pesos si
esta es la tasa de inflación dentro de
un año costará 102 pesos entonces hay
dos formas en las que se calcula la tasa
de interés real dada la tasa de interés
nominal y la tasa de inflación
la primera es una aproximación es muy
simple y se puede hacer en la mente y es
por eso que generalmente se piensa
primero en esta forma pero no es exacta
no es matemáticamente correcta así que
en esta primera forma diríamos bueno
esto es aproximadamente igual a la tasa
de interés nominal menos la tasa de
inflación entonces podemos decir que
esto es aproximadamente igual a 5 %
menos 2%
lo que sería igual a 3% y esta es una
buena aproximación pero si quieres un
resultado más preciso matemáticamente la
forma real para calcular esto es que tu
tasa de interés nominal multiplica el
dinero por 1.05 pero las cosas se
consiguen más caras a razón del 2% por
año otra forma de pensar en esto es que
los costos se multiplican por 1.02 cada
año entonces dividimos entre 1.0 2 y
esto nos da un 1.05 entre 1.0 2
es igual a 1.0 294 1.0 294 y esto nos da
un mejor sentido de la tasa de interés
real está más precisa en 2.94 por ciento
esta es una diferencia muy pequeña por
eso a la gente le gusta este método lo
puedes resolver en la mente y el
resultado es muy cercano pero recuerda
que aún los cambios pequeños en el
interés pueden hacer una gran diferencia
en muchos años de interés compuesto
hemos hablado sobre interés compuesto y
capitalización en otros vídeos hasta el
próximo vídeo